[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans
scienceclic les rotations de
l'espace-temps
nous vivons dans un espace géométrique
dans lequel nous pouvons nous déplacer
tourner mesurer des longueurs ou des
angles chaque personne possède son
propre référentiel nous avons tous notre
point de vue personnel de l'univers dont
nous sommes le centre et qui nous permet
de repérer les objets autour de nous
dans le référentiel de cette personne
par exemple la voiture se déplace
mais dans le référentiel de son
conducteur c'est la personne qui se
déplace
un référentiel permet de décrire
l'univers selon un point de vue donné
trois axes suffisent gauche-droite au
bas avant arrière
mais au début du 20e siècle cette vision
est bouleversée lorsque l'on comprend
que le temps est une quatrième dimension
de l'Univers il existe un quatrième axe
qu'il faut prendre en compte dans la
géométrie des référentiels
dans cette vidéo nous allons tenter de
comprendre cette révolution qui permet
d'unifier non seulement l'espace et le
temps mais également les champs
électriques et magnétiques ou encore le
mouvement et l'énergie
imaginons une rue dans laquelle sont
repérés une personne a au bord de la
route et une personne B au volant d'une
voiture
la voiture avance par rapport à la route
et pour décrire son mouvement nous
allons construire un diagramme
d'espace-temps
pour ce faire on immortalise chaque
instant
et on empile les clichés les uns sur les
autres ils forment un bloc qui
représente l'écoulement du temps
dans ce bloc les deux personnes avancent
vers le futur et trace chacune une ligne
d'univers
la personne a trace une ligne droite
vers le futur alors que la personne B
qui se déplace suit une trajectoire
inclinée
chaque tranche du diagramme repère la
position des objets à un instant donné
jusque là la situation est décrite du
point de vue de la route dans le
référentiel de la personne a mais à quoi
ressemblerait le diagramme si on
demandait au conducteur de la voiture de
leur redessiner de son point de vue
dans son référentiel B est au centre de
l'univers pour former son diagramme il
faut donc décaler toutes les tranches
les unes après les autres pour le
replacer au centre de la scène
la voiture est désormais immobile et
c'est la personne a qui semble défiler
vers l'arrière
on vient d'effectuer une transformation
de Galilée décaler les tranches
successives d'espace permet de changer
de référentiel
les physiciens comprennent ainsi dès le
17e siècle que le mouvement dépend de
l'observateur pour a c'est B qui se
déplacent mais pour B c'est a qui est en
mouvement
aucune de ces deux affirmations n'est
plus vrai que l'autre le mouvement est
relatif
par ailleurs si B décide de lancer une
balle
la vitesse de la balle semblera plus
élevée pour a puisqu'elle est emportée
par la voiture
selon Galilée on peut additionner les
vitesses pour changer de référentiel
cette idée peut paraître naturelle et
intuitive mais à l'orée du 20e siècle
une découverte va tout remettre en cause
imaginons que chacune des deux personnes
allume une lampe torche
[Musique]
si on néglige la présence de l'air qui
la ralentit la lumière s'échappe des
deux lampes à la vitesse vertigineuse de
299 millions 792 458 mètres par seconde
vu depuis la route on s'attendrait à ce
que le rayon lancé par B se déplace plus
vite par addition avec le mouvement de
la voiture
mais contre toute attente les deux
faisceaux ont exactement la même vitesse
avec stupeur les physiciens découvrent
que cette vitesse bien précise est
absolue quel que soit l'objet qui se
déplace à 299 millions 792 458 mètres
par seconde il aura cette même vitesse
dans tous les référentiels on la bâtisse
vitesse de la lumière
le choc est drastique et remettant cause
les transformations de Galilée comment
est-il possible que cette vitesse ne
s'additionne pas à celle de la voiture
pourquoi contrairement à la balle la
lumière ne change-t-elle pas de vitesse
d'un point de vue à l'autre
pour saisir l'ampleur du problème
imaginons que a émettent deux rayons
lumineux de part et d'autre
dans son référentiel les deux rayons ont
la même vitesse
mais dans le référentiel de B le
diagramme se déforme par rapport au
précédent la lumière devrait s'y
déplacer plus vite dans un sens que dans
l'autre pourtant elle reste la même
la solution sera trouvée par plusieurs
chercheurs au début du 20e siècle pour
que la vitesse de la lumière reste
invariante conformément aux observations
il faut déformer le diagramme en
décalant non seulement les tranches
d'espace mais aussi les tranches de
temps
les chercheurs n'ont pas le choix cette
manipulation est la seule qui permet de
changer de référentiel tout en
conservant la vitesse de la lumière dans
les deux sens et ce sans déformer les
lignes droites ou les volumes du
diagramme
il s'agit d'une transformation de
Lorentz
l'idée est bouleversante de manière
contre-intuitive le temps et l'espace se
déforment et change d'orientation selon
l'observateur les durées entre les
événements
l'ordre dans lequel il se produisent et
même la longueur des objets deviennent
des mesures relatives qui changent d'un
point de vue à un autre
ces deux événements par exemple se
produisent à une seconde d'intervalle
dans ce référentiel mais à une seconde
et un dixième dans cet autre référentiel
et la voiture mesure 4 mètres dans son
référentiel mais elle est légèrement
plus courte dans le référentiel de la
route
lorsqu'un corps se déplace dans notre
référentiel son horloge nous semble
tourner au ralenti et sa longueur nous
semble contracter
c'est la relativité restreinte
faisons une parenthèse
si on la regarde du dessus une ville
peut être décrite sur une carte qui
repère les routes et leur agencement
si l'on fait tourner la carte la
position et la Direction des Routes
semblent changer mais bien sûr ce n'est
qu'une illusion l'orientation de la
carte est arbitraire c'est une
description abstraite du monde qui
n'impacte pas la réalité
les physiciens vont rapidement faire
l'analogie entre le diagramme
d'espace-temps et une carte en effet
comme une carte le diagramme n'est
qu'une représentation abstraite de
l'univers et comme sur une carte on peut
changer de point de vue pour le regarder
dit autrement les transformations de
Lorent qui permettent de changer de
référentiel serait l'équivalent des
rotations de notre carte
cette idée fait sens car l’instar des
rotations les transformations de Lorent
conservent les lignes droites et les
volumes
mais contrairement à des rotations
classiques les transformations de Lorent
semblent déformer le diagramme elle ne
conserve pas les distances entre les
points certains s'éloignent d'autres
s'approchent
et alors que les rotations traces des
cercles
elle trace des hyperboles
[Musique]
comment de telles transformations
pourraient être analogue à des rotations
l'idée de génie reviendra à Poincaré et
Minkovski les chercheurs inventent une
nouvelle façon de mesurer les distances
dans le diagramme la métrique de
Minkowski
selon eux notre diagramme est abstrait
et ne représente pas fidèlement les
vrais distance dans l'espace-temps un
peu comme un planisphère qui déforme la
surface de la Terre pour la mettre à
plat
même s'ils n'en n'ont pas l'air tous les
points qui composent une hyperbole
seraient en réalité à la même distance
du centre
et ainsi l'hyperbole serait l'analogue
d'un cercle la courbe dont tous les
points se situent à la même distance du
centre
en changeant de référentiel les points
glissent le long des hyperboles et reste
tous à la même distance du centre
avec la métrique de Minkowski l'analogie
devient parfaite et les transformations
de Lorent sont bien l'analogue des
rotations ce sont des rotations
hyperboliques
contrairement à une rotation classique
qui peut tourner dans tous les sens une
rotation hyperbolique distingue deux
types de direction les durées d'une part
que l'on peut ramener sur l'axe du temps
et les longueurs d'autre part que l'on
peut ramener sur l'axe
[Musique]
les durées et les longueurs sont des
intervalles de nature différente des
intervalles de temps ou d'espace et les
rayons lumineux forment un cône qui les
sépare fondamentalement quelle que soit
le référentiel une durée reste une durée
et une longueur reste une longueur
ainsi puisque chaque observateur avance
vers son propre futur il est impossible
de remonter le temps nous sommes
confinés dans ces cônes de lumière et
dans tous les référentiels le futur
reste le futur
[Musique]
une rotation classique finit toujours
par boucler sur elle-même après 360
degrés
mais une rotation hyperbolique peut
tourner indéfiniment car l'angle de la
rotation ne se mesure plus sur un cercle
mais sur une hyperbole qui se prolonge à
l'infini on peut ainsi faire tourner
l'espace-temps autant que l'on veut
l'angle d'une rotation d'espace-temps
est baptisée la rapidité il mesure à
quel point un référentiel est rapide par
rapport à un autre
la rapidité de la voiture par exemple
par rapport à la route est l'angle entre
son référentiel et celui de la route si
la voiture accélère sa rapidité augmente
et en accélérant infiniment longtemps
elle finirait par rejoindre la vitesse
de la lumière
ainsi la vitesse de la lumière
correspondent en réalité à une rapidité
infinie c'est la vitesse maximale qu'un
objet ne pourrait atteindre qu'en
accélérant infiniment longtemps
la lumière est infiniment rapide
[Musique]
quand B lance une balle ce n'est pas sa
vitesse qui s'additionne à celle du
véhicule mais sa rapidité
et ainsi camper émet de la lumière
puisque sa rapidité est infinie
elle reste la même lorsqu'on lui ajoute
celle de la voiture
en révélant tous ces concepts les
physiciens découvrent peu à peu la
géométrie de l'espace-temps bien plus
qu'un diagramme abstrait l'espace-temps
est désormais une entité physique à part
entière dotée de distance et de rotation
cette nouvelle vision permettra aux
scientifiques de comprendre que le temps
et l'espace ne sont que les dimensions
d'un seul objet l'espace-temps
l'espace-temps permet de mieux
comprendre la notion d'accélération par
exemple en physique classique on dit
qu'un objet accélère lorsqu'il change de
mouvement soit en changeant de vitesse
soit en changeant de direction
mais dans l'espace-temps on comprend que
ces deux cas sont tous deux des
rotations une rotation classique ou une
rotation hyperbolique
accélérer revient en fait à tourner dans
l'espace-temps
l'espace-temps permet également
d'unifier les champs électriques et
magnétiques
un champ électrique génère une force qui
accélère les particules chargées tandis
qu'un champ magnétique génère une force
qui fait tourner les particules chargées
ces deux situations sont en fait
analogues comme le champ magnétique le
champ électrique fait tourner les
particules mais avec des rotations
hyperboliques dans l'espace-temps
le champ électrique et la version
temporelle du champ magnétique
enfin cette vision permet d'unifier les
notions de quantité de mouvement et
d'énergie
l'énergie est en fait l'analogue
temporelle de la quantité de mouvement
alors que l'une mesure le mouvement dans
l'espace l'autre mesure le mouvement
dans le temps
un objet immobile par exemple n'a pas de
quantité de mouvement il ne se déplace
pas dans l'espace mais il a une énergie
car il se déplace dans le temps vers le
futur
et si l'objet accélère sa vitesse change
il tourne dans l'espace-temps et gagne
en quantité de mouvement et en énergie
en approchant la vitesse de la lumière
ces deux grandeurs tentent vers l'infini
les transformations de Lorens ne sont
que des rotations abstraites de notre
carte de l'univers des changements de
point de vue qui n'affectent pas la
vraie géométrie de l'espace-temps mais
dans les années suivantes Einstein et
ses contemporains découvriront que
l'univers peut réellement se déformer ce
courbé à proximité des astres massifs
expliquant le phénomène de gravité c'est
la relativité générale
la théorie de la relativité restreinte
n'est pas abandonnée pour autant comme
la terre qui est courbe mais semble
plate à petit échelle l'espace-temps est
courbe mais est encore décrit à petit
échelle par la métrique de Minkowski
elle est à la base de notre
compréhension de l'univers
aujourd'hui de nouvelles théories
tentent de comprendre cette géométrie à
l'échelle fondamentale l'espace-temps
est-il parfaitement lisse ou alors
découpé en petits grains
comporte-t-il davantage de dimensions
qui seraient recroquevillée et donc
invisible à notre échelle
ou peut-être qu'il fluctue au gré
d'agitation quantique
les idées foisonnent dans l'espoir
d'obtenir un jour une compréhension
fondamentale de l'univers
[Musique]